Hey everybody.
Welcome to the podcast.
Today's guest, next in line
in my ongoing series of conversations
from my week span in Minneapolis is outdoor activist
and youth educator, Anthony Taylor, joining me
for a conversation about the power of nature,
power of open spaces, and of course adventure
to empower particularly young people.
And of course, the importance of
expanding the inclusivity of the spaces to everybody.
A super fit avid outdoors man accomplished ultra cyclist
and at 62, the very model of anti-aging.
Anthony is the former commissioner
for Minneapolis's Parks and Open Spaces.
And currently serves as Senior Vice President
of Equity, Outdoors, and Nature for YMCA of the North.
He's also the founder
of the Major Taylor Bicycling Club of Minneapolis.
He serves on the League of American Bicyclists
Equity Advisory Board, as well as the Board
of the National Brotherhood of Skiers.
He's the co-founder of Cool Meets Cause,
an outreach program that teaches girls
from North Minneapolis to snowboard.
And he served as the adventure director
for the Loppet Foundation,
a program that provides year-round outdoor activities
for youth in Minneapolis.
Anthony is an absolute gem of a human.
This conversation is D O P E dope,
it's definitely a fav
so hit that subscribe button and let's do it.
This is me and Anthony Taylor.
I mean, you're kind of a community leader at large, right?
Like you're just sort of out there in the outdoor spaces
trying to get people excited about being outdoors.
You're with the YMCA now, right?
Is that the official-
Yeah.
It's what you know and I should say it's like the job,
but I think you're right.
I feel like I'm an accidental advocate.
I really had the great opportunity, I don't know
seven years ago to really step back
from business entrepreneurship
and then I decided what I was going to do
and this new startup organization
called the Loppet Foundation
was about to do this big capital campaign
and do something that hadn't been done
which was do a partnership with the park and programming
and from really from where we are right now,
we're five minutes from Theodore Wirth Park
which is this amazing park in the middle of the city,
the same size of Central Park as a matter of fact.
Is it really that big?
Is that big.
Wow.
And so we had this idea of, well, let's build
this outdoors instead of a health club
where you go in and work out,
this is a health club building where you go in
but everything pushes you outside.
Right.
So you come in and change clothes,
go for a mountain bike ride, go for a ski,
go for a trail run, go for a bike ride
and that was the idea, but really what was unique about it
is that it was crapped right in the middle of
the densest population of African-Americans in twin cities.
Right.
So if we're going to do this we have an obligation, right
to connect this geography to the black community
in North Minneapolis, right?
Yeah.
And so that began me working really in community
and what I say is like,
everybody thinks they know the solution from public schools.
Well, and I say that
the truth of the matter is that it's like,
the only thing that makes you an expert
on being a parent is not having kids.
Right.
(laughs)
It's the same thing, right?
So we know all the solutions for public schools
until you're in a public school.
You know all the solutions around
working in the African community or working in
under-resourced communities or communities
where they are challenged are the worst performing schools.
However, you know how to do that
until you're doing it, right.
And that was a formative experience.
That was seven years ago, eight years ago and
it just changed the way that I do work.
In what way?
Is that one, I think
it changed the way I view
the people or the community, because I think
that the way that we start,
often we do this in youth development,
we do this with communities of color,
we do it with challenge communities
is that we believe they need to be fixed.
Like, we actually believe that, truth of the matter is
something's wrong and we can fix it, right.
Rather than thinking about them as really
this whole person responding to all the inputs on it
and they're in the real foundation of them is that
they are an asset to be cultivated and developed, right.
And that they will then be part of creating solutions
to make themselves stronger, better.
You know what I mean?
And so, you make that shift mentally,
and then you literally start doing programming differently.
And that's what I mean-
From the perspective of
respecting and empowering the young people
and trusting in them to
basically forge the future that we're trying to repair.
And you know, what else?
Is you wouldn't...
Children don't exist alone.
So that even that is a...
Do you know any kids who exist alone?
You know any kids who buy groceries?
No.
You know any kids...
Some, but I mean, generally
so even that is one of those things that you shifted.
You go, it's not a child, it's a family.
Like, so if you're going to actually influence a child
who you really have to influence?
The parents.
And if you're really going to be influenced the parents
who do you have to be?
You have to be the cool uncle that shows up on the weekend
and says the same thing the parents say.
Right.
Well, the cool uncle is often more influential
on the child's behavior
because the kids don't want to hear it from the parents.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm saying so that's a fun...
So now you're a partner to the parent,
same values, same perspective, different voice.
Right.
So that is a true DASA dramatically different approach
to working with youth and working with families, right.
And who's the real influencer?
The parent.
So now all of a sudden you start...
So you see what I'm saying?
It's like, it's a...
And I think that that's a very...
That's just one way that it influenced
the work around it but,
it's just like, that's something and I learned a lot
like being in those schools,
we think educators are a challenge.
Well, our educators are challenge,
our parents are challenge, our kid...
Who's the challenge.
But when you work in schools
you have a lot of people in the ecosystem.
Right.
And you're constrained by the bureaucracy
and the traditions that are based-
That's exactly right.
And so then here's the bureaucracy built into now,
post George Floyd, no one actually has a problem saying
that the system is the challenge
and the systemic racism, right.
Historical marginalization.
I mean, there all those things are real
and so therefore where we have to work together
and influence that is changing what,
we change the people or we start impacting the system
that are impacting people.
Right.
That perspective, or that
idea about how to solve the problem,
spans the spectrum from let's just blow it up completely to,
well, we need to work piecemeal within the system.
We kind of know how that works,
nothing really seems to ever change
in a fundamental way when you do that.
But what really forges real change?
How do you see, the progress within our
generational lifetime?
Yeah.
Well, and that's, I think,
the idea of changing in a generational lifetime
like that is actually a really big idea
that this is generational change.
And I think, even when you say that,
I mean, think about the times
as an adult over time, where when you
talk to people about what's happening
and they think about it in this moment.
Right, versus it being generational.
Right, I mean, even that idea is like, really-
(chuckles)
Right.
It's the legacy of decades past.
That's exactly right.
But when you look
at the young people, I mean, imagine you're a parent, right.
How old are your kids?
10 and 16.
10, 16, all right.
So you're a 10 year old kid you're growing up
amidst everything that's happening here,
what does it look like when you're 40?
When they inherit the legacy of what's transpiring now
that gives me hope and optimism.
Well, it gives me hope and I agree,
it really gives me hope and optimism.
But I will say that one of the things that's changed
is that 40 year olds, right.
And actually even longer than that.
And I think Minnesota is a really great example of this
and I think, I don't know, East Coast is even
a stronger example of this actually.
Is that, that if you talk to someone old enough,
if you talk to your grandparents,
they will tell you, they remember when they weren't white.
Right.
So in Minnesota what we have going on
is we've got the Swedes, the Finns, Norwegians,
the Jews, the Germans, you got all those, right.
Somalians too.
But they're new.
That's new to this.
And they always been black.
I'm saying that if you talk to people old enough
they will remember when white people weren't white.
Meaning like the Irish in New York
City or wherever.
Absolutely.
The Irish in New York City-
Who is the underclass kind of shifts?
Right.
Not only the underclass, the inhumane.
So you have to kind of really think about the fact that
that in the beginning of this experiment,
white people moved here and they weren't white.
They were Irish, or they were Finnish
or they were German or whatever the hell they were
but you know what they didn't get,
they didn't get to be white yet.
They hadn't earned that, right.
And so the idea...
I mean, it's just...
And so here, we...
Matter of fact, I grew up in Milwaukee, right.
So, you know what it really, like, as far as the Polish
the jokes about Polish I just, that always,
I didn't get that for a long time when I was a kid, right.
But people love telling those jokes, right.
(both laugh)
But as I got older, I kinda, I got.
So they were the low white people.
But the systemic aspect of it
was baked into it is the implied or implicit,
like, idea that at some point you aspire to
or you inherit this mantle of being white, right.
Like, that's...
It's like, when do you get accepted
as being a member of the white class.
That's right.
So you have to exactly say so when
do you get to be white?
It's not even...
That you don't even...
And the people that inherited are the second
but the first generation of people,
they knew they weren't white.
They knew they were Finnish or Norwegian or German.
And you know what?
I mean, still the Swedes don't like the Norwegians,
the Norwegians don't like the Swedes, they gang up
and don't like the Finns
and thank God black people came along
because now the Finns got to get in the club.
Right.
It just begets the cycle of like,
when do we get to look down on somebody?
That's right.
And then socially, what we did in this country is we created
economic and social benefits for whiteness.
And that's, I don't even talk, I don't say white privilege,
I talk about the social benefits of whiteness.
And what we can talk about, if we look back long enough
we will see that there's been economic and social
benefits of whiteness to the point
that people drop the ski off their name,
drop the son off their name, they...
Right, 'cause you want to be Anders, not Anderson, right.
You, right.
You want to be, a Chickin instead of a Chickinski, right?
I mean, however you do that, all those things you do
to walk away from culture and this and your name and
your look and then you can become white
and then the benefits of that become
where you can live and then government wise,
there's always been benefits to becoming white.
There's always been benefits,
social and economic benefits of whiteness are real.
And they've been being compiled
for such a long time that nobody,
who the second generation doesn't know the truth of that.
And so here we are in Minneapolis,
in this moment right now where it does feel like this is,
it's a boiling over moment, right?
Like it's all coming to the surface.
And part of that back to this idea of hope or optimism like
when it's all out there,
now we have a chance to reckon with it, to grapple with it
and hopefully, craft a healthier future forward.
But how are you...
Like it's crazy out there right now.
There's Humvees everywhere, the curfews,
the Dante protests going up in Brooklyn center,
like, how are you feeling right now?
Like, what's going on inside your head?
How are you processing everything?
Yeah.
I think that the one thing that I'm actively proactively
trying to do, my own
maintenance around self care that's one.
I think the other thing is that being,
having a strategy for you have to take action.
Like, I think that helps.
I don't, I mean, for me, part of my work is I'm actually,
I'm actively taking action all the time around it right now
so the ability...
Like, even with the YMCA you asked,
one of the things we're doing with the YMCA
is saying we're going to make our camp properties
available for people to retreat.
Like just for free, we're going to create opportunities
for people to get outside and do for free.
But one thing that happened in the pandemic
is that it forced people to think
maybe I should go for a walk.
Like, I think that you know it's been... (laughs)
Like, so the idea of how do we position
people getting outside?
How are we creating spaces for people to do that?
How are we creating conversations for people,
giving people, forcing people to talk about it?
Because I think that one of the things that people thought
is the best strategy for me is if I just don't feel, right.
If I don't feel, if I become numb, then
I can get through this.
That's a coping mechanism.
It's just a coping mechanism.
It doesn't...
You don't actually not feel, right.
You still do that-
You still pressing it, yeah.
That's exactly right.
So that's what I really have been trying to do
is create outlets for really how I'm feeling,
connecting to people and creating opportunities
for them to do that, to go really, how am I feeling?
Like, how am I actually feeling,
and being conscious about the visual
kind of digestion of it.
Like, I've been very conscious not to watch the news
first thing in the morning, not to do this, not to do that,
try to figure out how to get away from that dull noise
and that distraction.
Right.
All day.
And how are your kids dealing with it?
My ten-year-old actually the thing,
for her is actually when you just go,
the physical presence of seeing the national guard
on a street that is normally really...
Like that is kind of,
messes her up a little bit, right.
Because that doesn't make sense or helicopters
or like all those things that are disturbing.
So really, for her, it's been really working through that
like and just talking actively and reframing,
why they're here, what can we do
and creating rituals for her to go to bed
really anchoring ourselves in rituals
of eating and activity
and those kinds of things for her to be calm, my son is 16.
And for him, and you know when you're talking
about the young people, as a 16 year old,
one of the things...
And actually one of the things you said
but one of the things that gives me hope
is that these young people, their reality, first of all
it's significantly more integrated than ours ever was.
Yeah.
They also have had social justice baked into their
reality.
Right.
Like they have always known social justice
even if it's just
non-binary gender...
Like they are open, right?
So he has white friends that they have aligned together
and going to protests, right.
That those young people are understanding the language of
social justice and around white evolution around...
You know what I mean?
Like the evolution of young white advocates,
if you talk to them,
like they know all the language of being an ally,
they understand privilege, they talk about stepping back.
I mean, it's a very interesting thing.
You watch them moving together.
It actually is pretty unbelievable.
Yeah.
And playing a support role
in terms of your power and privilege,
providing food, providing connect...
I mean, like there's something that they're doing
in terms of a dance right now
that is actually pretty compelling.
And I think you're right,
the challenge is that they also, they're not afraid.
Right.
They're 16 to 22 so they don't have any healthy fear either.
(both laugh)
Right.
That imperviousness with those hormones that
you have at that age.
That's exactly right.
For sure.
And the adrenaline is worth it all, right.
There's a part of them that, that is-
That can go south though.
Like, 16, you get angry and shit go sideways.
That's exactly right.
And that is the value of intergenerational conversation.
Like, so even that's one of the things I think about,
in terms of why we have to stay connected
to our young people.
We may not be on the front line
but we have to stay connected to them.
We have to offer advisory, we have to offer some of
those opportunities to kind of bring them down a little bit
create those
bumpers.
We want them to go out there and throw
their body at the pans, but let's put some bumpers out
(both laugh)
so they hit some pans, right.
Right.
But yeah, no, I think you're absolutely right
and like I said, I think that's the value
of intergenerational work.
And the role that we play,
I really, I think that the 40 year olds
and the 50 year olds have to find their role
in this movement too and part of it is an advisory role.
And then the 65 old, 75 year olds
like they were there in 1965.
Right.
So there's also an element of opportunity for them
to really engage from an experiential.
I mean, you know what I'm saying?
Like, that's a...
What kind of missed opportunity is that
if we don't connect 1965 to 2000
to 2001 to 2021.
Right.
In terms of the moment because they look similar.
Yeah.
It actually looks-
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And even in terms of the
multi-generational movement of it,
it was a multiracial movement.
Yeah.
Tying to that legacy feels like,
I mean, if you were somebody who participated in that
in that time and you're in your sixties or seventies now
there's so much to be learned from that experience
but also I suspect some level of jadedness.
Like we did this before man, and
look we're still doing it again.
Like, are we just going to keep doing this?
Well, and
so that's going to be a great interview to see that.
But I think that the jadedness,
the ones that are jaded
sometimes feel also unacknowledged.
Like I think there's an aspect
of it that is also acknowledging that it began.
Like, this is not new.
Like, even if we just acknowledge that this is not new
it puts us in a very different position, right.
In terms of how we move forward.
And I think,
that's something that is
very American too, right.
Is that we overvalue 20,
generally.
We own a value the moment of the 20 year old in general
and that is something-
Yeah, we've lost the reverence
for the wisdom of the elders.
That's exactly right.
For sure.
That's right.
And I think this could be an opportunity for us
in some regard do that again, to make that connection
because I do think that they have learned something.
And more importantly,
where I think we really get value from them probably
is the post movement movement that didn't happen.
Because I think the thing they would say is
they became complacent.
They thought that those initial things
around policy actually were a solution.
And they were just the beginning,
or they got old and bought a Volvo.
I don't know what they're going to say,
but you know what I mean?
(both laugh)
That at some point,
even as we think about this, what do we do?
The challenge for us is, is not to stop, right.
I mean, that we...
You get a verdict, okay.
(exhales)
Right.
We're good,
problem-
Or we'll get a verdict that goes the other way
and we were talking about that before the podcast, right?
Like, everybody's thinking about
what's going to happen next week or
over the next several days, if and when the jury comes back,
how are you preparing for that?
What does that look like?
And there's a stress associated with that, right?
Like there's a trauma to that
that you're carrying around on some low level at all times.
That's right.
And that's...
When we keep thinking about it
especially preparing for a non guilty verdict, right?
There's like and I've heard two different things.
One is the people who are saying,
I actually don't have hope for it.
That's a bad place to be.
And then there are the people that go,
it's not gonna happen but we're ready to protest.
Or how do we protect against the protest?
Or, how do we, like I said, how do we protect
against the fact that people are gonna respond
and be upset against a lesser charge?
And I think,
what I'm feel like I'm trying to do in my circles
is say to people,
let's separate from the trial that's going on.
Let's really think aspirationally
for what is it we want to create
in terms of the world we're going to live in.
Like, really what are the characteristics
of the outcome of this movement of
this awakening that we have had
as a community around what the challenge is, right?
What is it we really want to look like?
And what are the things we need to do that?
So, because that is independent of the trial.
Right.
And irrespective of the outcome
or whatever the verdict is, there's always
an opportunity, right.
So if it doesn't go the way that you would like it to go
where is the opportunity in that
to forge the change you wanna see?
Well, and honestly, if you and I visualize
a practical experience of what it looks like
for there to be equity for social justice to be realized
for us to...
If we think about that, independent of the trial
really we're creating what the opportunity is.
And if we know what that is
and you and I work to define,
well, what is the work we have to do to do that?
That's independent of the trial.
Right, it's being proactive
rather than just responding or reacting to
external circumstances you don't have any control over.
And that's the key part.
We actually don't have control
over what's going to happen there.
But what we can do is visualize what that future looks like,
start defining what the work is for that
and let's move towards that.
Because the truth is that is actually
more empowering for us, right.
It actually puts our energy in a good place.
It gives us a hopeful vision for the future.
I mean, and now you and I can immediately
talk about how we ally.
Right.
We can describe what that looks like.
Well, what resources are you bringing to bear?
You're bringing media, you're bringing this reach.
What am I bringing to bear?
I'm actually, I'm going to say, no
I'm bringing bikes and people.
We're going to do, whatever we're going to do
that does this we can start to plan for that now.
We don't have to...
The trial, doesn't have to dictate that.
Right, right.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want to snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually,
already know how to eat better and
aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say is
The Plantpower Meal Planner are affordable,
all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com
and right now, for a limited time we're offering
$10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people,
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right.
Let's get back to the show.
Meanwhile, you are getting bikes to people, right?
You got like 300 bikes to essential workers
and stuff like that.
Like you were handing out bikes like candy bars.
Oh wow.
Kinda.
Well, you know what, last year,
when COVID-19 shut everything down,
it was just an accidental
thing that perked up on our radar which was...
And matter of fact
the first place we noticed it was New York
which is really interesting, right?
That the essential workers in New York realized that the,
let me say the medical community realized
the worst place you could be
if you want to actually stay healthy
is public transportation.
Yeah.
Right?
So the people who had the ability said, okay, I can bike.
And they, you guys got City bike in New York
so people started using those, there wasn't enough of them.
They couldn't keep them clean,
they took them off the streets
so then people started buying bikes.
Bike shops were out of bikes in end of March.
Yeah I know.
And their supply chain's all messed up
so you can't even get new bikes they're all sold out.
That's right, they couldn't new bikes.
It was such a mad rush on bikes.
So here in the twin cities, quality, bicycle parts
is Bastyr, most people don't know that.
They're probably the largest distributor
of bike parts in the world
and they're based like 15 minutes from here.
So we have relationships there
and they were already telling us they were out of tubes,
like crazy, weird stuff.
So then we said, okay, well, how do we support
essential workers who aren't the high earners,
who weren't the early adapters and get bikes to them?
So that was really the goal was that
we worked with another local organization here
called Free Bikes For Kids,
and actually Allina Medical, Allina Healthcare.
We got 300 bikes and then we just reached out
and again, the goal was really the frontline workers
in our essential worker community
and we made bikes available for free.
And we made bikes and helmets
and locks available then for free
and all they had to do is say
that they needed one and then they would ride to work.
And that was really the initiative.
And then once we did that
we found out they needed bikes for their families.
Right.
So then we organized another set of bikes
and then we gave those to the family members
of those essential workers.
And this is back in March and April
so as you know, Minnesota
summer hadn't even broken yet, right.
And then in May it became helping people
actually have success with riding new bikes.
So people got new bikes, people were trying to use them
and so then we really focused our energy on
and helping people have a successful experience-
Yeah, it's such a powerful lever
because once you have that bike,
it represents so many things, fitness,
of course, but also freedom.
You have the ability to roam.
And then, I know this is a big part
of your advocacy, but once you're out on a bike
and you're not in an Uber or a taxi
or a train or whatever, you have a tactile relationship
with the neighborhoods
that you're kind of navigating through
and it really changes the frame with which you
interact with those neighborhoods
and the people that live there.
You hit the nail on the head is that in truth
is not even about the bike, right.
It is literally about re-framing the relationship you have
to the place you live.
Right.
And really for...
Especially in challenged communities,
there's a disconnect you make
to the geography you live in some ways.
Right.
You just, you teleport in and teleport out, right.
And you live in your house.
Right and instead of living in your community,
right.
Yeah.
And there are lots of reasons for that.
But that's exactly right, it re-frames
the relationship to the place you live.
And really, in a big picture way,
isn't the history of racism,
the history of the way that we have xenophobia,
the history of gender bias is actually
all about limiting mobility.
Like this is...
Or controlling the body.
Like if you really think about it
in those gross terms, controlling the body, right.
Limiting mobility has really been always the point.
So the bike itself actually represents this
initial break through in terms of creating mobility.
Like it's about mobility moving through your neighborhood,
moving around the city with freedom, right.
And as you want to in a self-propelled manner.
Right.
And so the symbolism of that is really big.
Yeah, it's transgressive in that regard,
when you juxtapose that or contextualize it against
what happened in Chicago in what was it?
1919.
Yeah.
When the black person walked down the beach
and crossed that imaginary line into the white beach,
and it caused all those riots, like
this is the evolution of that in a way to
deconstruct those boundaries.
That are not like,
they're invisible boundaries.
That's right.
And that really is insightful, I think
and you, one of the few people who actually know that
like, I think that's even in terms of us
putting this in the context of history,
which is the generational piece of it, right.
Is that that 1919 event
and one of the things I pointed out a lot is because
I'm always saying to people that you have to realize
that this issue of outdoors and equity
is really important because one of the first great riots
around race in this country started
over an imaginary line on a beach in Lake Michigan, right.
Around this access to public space
who has a right to be where
and it could cost you your life.
And that was the first one but there's been multiple
versions of that same thing.
And more recently, when you look at
the last desegregated spaces in America
were public green spaces, were public pools.
And as a matter of fact, white America
in St. Louis or Milwaukee, Kansas city, Detroit,
rather than let black people
in public pools in those spaces, they'd rather,
they shut them down.
They shut them down.
Yeah.
I mean, all you have to do is study the history
of public pools in America and
it's literally a history of race relations.
It's incredible.
There's a woman called Bonnie Tsui who wrote a book
called "Why We Swim" she was on the podcast and
a big part of that book is about that
and it's super fascinating.
I grew up in the Washington DC metropolitan area,
I was originally from Michigan and
one of the things I realized
when we moved to Washington is
there aren't that many pools.
There used to be...
In the Midwest there's pools
at all the high schools for the most part, right.
And suddenly there aren't why not?
Well, it all goes back to
that very thing that you're speaking about.
Yeah
No, I think, and that's, again, a really,
just the kind of the point of why public green space,
why outdoors represents something very significant
relative to our fight around racism.
Like that's exactly right.
And I think that, again, we don't...
Even now, we can actually predict
all significant disparities by zip code.
It doesn't matter disparities in healthcare,
disparities in education, disparities in income,
education, educational attainment, you can predict
every one of those by zip code in America right now.
And that is grounded in the work that was done
for segregation beginning in the early 19 hundreds as well.
The initial things around red lining all flowed
from the FHA mortgages.
So from federally backed mortgages
that was the beginning of it, right.
Created those delineations.
And this city is no different than that.
It was all around space and land.
Yeah.
Yeah, this idea that black bodies in
public natural spaces have always been managed
and controlled strikes
people in a counterintuitive way
because when you think of outdoor spaces or public parks,
the kind of knee jerk reaction, at least,
me being a white dude is they're open spaces.
Like they're open to everybody.
What are you talking about?
So it requires a more kind of nuanced
historically grounded education to understand
why they're not as open as one might suspect.
So talk a little bit about, what that means.
The first thing that you described right away is,
they are public, but they are controlled.
That we've done a lot of things
and there's two pieces of me.
And one of the piece I think that we often miss is that
the movement of black people from the South to the North
all happened in one window of time, right?
So the great migration happens,
really but between 1950 and 1970 let's call, right.
And when all those people moved here
they were outdoors people.
That's the one thing I said,
that was were black people connected to the land.
They farmed fundamentally.
They fished, they hunted,
there was a connection to the land.
There's a long legacy of that, right.
And even in Washington, DC area
as soon as you're not in DC, you're in the country.
You're in Virginia, you're in West Virginia, you're...
So there were people connected to the land.
Beginning in the late sixties, early seventies
you start to see this collection of people in cities.
Right.
And the first thing they did was control
where black bodies could go.
So they actually created areas that were where
you could live in places you couldn't live.
Right.
And then those parks, right.
We want up patrolling, controlling.
Right.
They weren't safe in that regard.
And the other thing that simultaneously happens is
the beginning of creating the identity
of blackness as urban.
Right.
The idea that urban and black is synonymous.
That's exactly right.
Is a new thing.
I mean, but it's only new if you think 4 years is new.
Since we're old enough to go that's new.
But you know what I mean like that kind of idea
but new would be, that's what I say.
One of the negative things about the internet
is history is what happened last week
and that's how anything older than that is pre-history.
And so but you're absolutely right.
The last 40, 50 years has been the creation where we,
when you say urban, you could mean black.
And as a matter of fact
usually when people say urban, they mean black, right.
And so that's a new creation.
And that grounding of identity is really been based
on the fact that policing, geography, banking, housing
has all been about controlling black bodies into
very specific geography.
Right.
And they're dense, they're not green.
It hasn't been a commitment to using natural spaces,
a necessary need for wellbeing
which is how we talk about it right now, right.
And so that's really significant.
And simultaneously, we get
the growth of the environmental movement,
as we see at the Sierra clubs and
those organizations are pop up out of the sixties.
And I think that though
that was really white America's response to black power.
Like- (chuckles)
That's interesting.
I've never heard that.
You know what I mean?
You would think about
when does the Women's Movement start,
the Black movement start, the Chicano American Movement
Latin X, whatever we call it that time.
When does the Gay Movement start
that all those movements start when, 65 to 75, right.
When does this movement emerge?
As we know it, same window of time.
Same window of time.
And so it's just an interesting way that that happens
and then as it simultaneously happens, we get the growth of
like outdoors is the lone adventure,
adventurer, you know you need a lot of gear
and this recreation, and that's what we've grown
in the last 50 years too, right.
And that's what well, and I'm that guy, right.
I get those jokes, but
(Rich laughs)
the rooftop rack, bike being on the front, this...
So all of a sudden,
this way that we've cultivated it now
is very different than, than what it used to be.
And because these are fundamentally socially
oriented events and really outdoors
is fundamentally a social pursuit,
we have to acknowledge America is socially segregated.
That fundamentally America is socially segregated.
So one of the things that black people, brown people do
when they're not at work
is they organize with other black and Brown people.
I guess like a recuperative strategy
because I gotta be in white America all day.
Like that's people like...
So the way that I balanced that
is when I have my social options, they're fundamentally
oriented towards whatever, who are your people are.
And so outdoors as we see it as recreation, social this
so what is it black people do when they...
They don't hang out with white people
on purpose, right.
Right.
Or they don't do that.
I mean, the trope of like black people, don't camp
black people, don't swim, they don't ride mountain bikes
or go surfing.
And then the kind of legacy of that notion
gets baked into the next generation of black people who then
believe that that is the case
and don't understand that there are
external forces that have created
that reality artificially.
That's right.
And young people, especially because,
that's one of the, I think working with young people's been
is that young people are always looking for authenticity.
Right, you know what I'm saying?
Like they want to do what's....
They keeping it real,
like that is real for them.
They want to keep it real.
They want to align with their identity,
and so if you look at young black kids,
they go, "I don't do that."
That's what they do.
I'm aligning with what blackness is, right.
I'm aligning with those things that validate
that identity that I have for myself.
Right.
And so that's part of it.
And their parents are the first generation
of people disconnected from outdoors.
Right.
So they don't do it either.
And if your parent isn't taking you guys to...
But as far as, even the black people, don't camp thing
what's interesting is simultaneously
and there's documentation for that here,
is black people did camp.
Like, you look at the 60 seventies, even the eighties,
there were and there's hardly any black people here.
That's one thing Minneapolis is not like,
it's definitely in DC.
(both laugh)
It might not even be Denver.
I don't know.
But I'm just saying that, I think that
there is documentation of Lake front properties
that were actually populated by our black families
from the twin cities.
Right.
Lake Adney is what it's called
that literally and is in the Minnesota.
And I know these families of those families
who summered at Lake Adney.
Right.
Wow
And they did that.
I mean, it's so-
It's kind of a...
It's similar to
the history of Manhattan beach and what's going on there
in Los Angeles right now with the reparations.
That's exactly and that's an amazing story, right.
But even in Martha's Vineyards.
There's a legacy-
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean it's still a black haven if you got the cash.
If you got the cash.
But the idea of a black Haven at Martha's Vineyard
in 1940, 1950 like people don't know, you know what I mean?
That's what I'm saying.
Even in the Poconos, even-
They now know because, Obama goes there
or whatever but-
That's right.
That's right, but they think it's because of money.
There's a whole legacy there.
Right.
They don't know that there's actually a long legacy
of that happening.
And, I mean, that's like...
And there were actually state parks
for black people in Georgia.
Wow.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
Until desegregation.
I mean like, so that's when I'm saying-
Segregated black park.
Segregated black.
A segregated state park outside Atlanta.
(Rich laughs)
Near stone mountain.
Yeah.
I mean, you know what I mean?
So this is like,
so that kind of is, that's what I mean.
And it was black, no black people did do that.
Matter of fact, there's a legacy of black people
being deeply engaged in those activities,
up until this kind of new urban focus
in terms of what it means.
And the part about that too,
that I would say that is interesting is that
there's always been parallel universes for black America.
Like, that's the way I remember it too
is you think about...
And professionally if you think
there's the journalist association,
there's a black journalist association.
There's the American bar association,
a national bar association.
So there's this way where black life
in some way guarded, emulated white life only black.
Yeah.
Well, the marginalization forces
that impulse to create their own community.
That's exactly right.
And so we had these parallel universes
of all these different things going on all the time.
It's always been that way.
So there's always been a black outdoor movement
even now there's a black RViars.
Like that's how we...
(Rich laughs)
No, right now go google it, black RViars.
It's a real thing of black people that are in RV
that connect to each other and get out so...
Well, there's also all these cool kind of,
black communities about the outdoors, like non-profits
or community-based organizations that are cropping up
like Outdoor Afro and Diversify Outdoors
and Melanin Base Camp.
Like, (chuckles)
Yup.
So that's happening in no small part.
I would imagine by the work that you're doing
to try to create advocacy, but so much of it would seem
social media kind of has its pluses and minuses but
the way I see it, I'm interested
in what you think about this is that,
hip hop culture predominates as,
the largest cultural force in America
or perhaps across the world.
And the influence of that on young people
is beyond profound, right?
But at the same time, you do have amazing black voices
that are in the outdoor space, who are out there killing it
and creating a different and new type of role model for
a young black person to model themselves after.
Well, and the modeling...
Well, let me-
And I'm not casting aspersions on hip hop,
I'm just saying they're different things.
I think that, the thing about hip hop,
two things about hip hop.
Hip hop ultimately became this actual
very shared experience for our black youth and white youth.
Like, that's one of the things I think that
is a shared kind of interesting experience for them
because aesthetically,
I feel like it...
Compared to when I was a kid,
I feel like you can no longer turn radio stations
and go who's listening.
Right.
Because you could do that for a very long time.
You knew the audience always
but you can't do that as easily.
You could not see a young person's clothes
and go, are they black or white?
So the style is very similar, right.
There's a much more shared social reality
that our young people have and hip hop-
A hundred percent.
Is part of that, right.
Hip hop-
It's a huge part of that.
That's what I'm saying, right.
So hip hop, the impact is in that regard
is really interesting.
The other thing that hip hop did
was teach people the idea
that I can vertical gain and rate my own money, right.
I mean, as much as I can be an artist,
I can be the producer, I can be the label.
As a matter of fact,
I'm gonna distribute this shit myself, right.
I mean-
I want the vertical
integration of everything that I do.
Everything, right?
Yeah.
So these young people now go,
I can be a corporation tomorrow.
There's a piece of that that is really interestingly
different, I think if you talk to black America and
even adults that are over 45,
they have a much more traditional trajectory
of terms of how they would get to success, right.
Go to college, like one of the pathways go to college,
get the right degree, get in corporate America,
do this Ascension, right.
A very-
Which is all about fitting in,
or like doing as you're told
or checking about this.
Assimilation.
Yeah.
Assimilation was a fundamental strategy
until hip hop, right.
And so not only did hip hop go against that
then the internet came along and allowed them
to actually have the tool to do it themselves.
And it just really changed the way that they saw the world
and kind of their identity.
So I think hip hop owes that I think the outdoor movement
fueled by young people, the thing that they decided to do.
And I do know that young people
and I know Rue Mapp at Outdoor Afro,
I mean, I know that people diversify outdoors.
I mean, these are people I know
but I'm going to say that I think they were more innovative
in some regards than I was, right.
Because I do think they're the new guard.
And I think that they focus
their energies on changing the narrative.
Like they were literally like, yes, we do.
Like that should be the website.
Yes, black people do.
'Cause that was kind of the...
We do climb.
Oh we do do this, we do do that.
And they then challenged the system
against the fact that they had to assimilate.
Right.
I mean, I think I've evolved
because when I first started doing this movement,
I just was trying to get black folks on bikes, right.
But you know what, they would have black people
that looked like the white people in spandex.
Like that was, you know what I mean?
(both laugh)
Right.
And right, I mean, that was...
And so but what evolved for me over time
was that that wasn't really the solution.
And so I've changed my strategies
and so now I'm much more aligned with them.
And then the organization that you didn't mention
that you probably, the idea of the global majority,
that organization is really interesting
because they're making the claim
that if there is solidarity past color,
and we look at the idea of not white and the global majority
then actually we are a majority.
And if we're a global majority probably
we maybe a majority outside, right.
Just in terms of if we...
So I think there...
So then that comes along and really changes things.
And I think that's really even for me
in terms of though the idea of what we're doing.
And so the stations you say that
you were naming those names
so we used to be Major Taylor Bicycling Club in Minnesota,
we've done all these different.
So the current movement that we're using here
in the twin cities and we're growing
is called Melanin in Motion.
And what's been deep is the response from the community
of people who said, I'm down with that.
Like, I think there was like...
And you know how...
And if you're an outdoors person, you know how you talk
to your friends and tell, and you say,
you should go biking with me and they go,
okay, yeah, I'll go biking.
But in their mind, what they're really saying
I am not going biking with that, dude.
He's going to hurt me.
Right.
I am not going to get dropped.
I'm not going to have the wrong bike.
I'm not going to have the wrong clothes.
Yeah.
Well, cycling's full of all that nonsense.
It is.
But that's what they're saying.
Well, the same thing with outdoors.
And so once we took it out of like,
no, all we're doing is moving.
We're a melanated community getting together,
we're going to move somehow.
It might be snowboarding.
It might be cross-country skiing.
It might be biking.
It might be hiking.
It might be snowshoeing and there's no judgment.
So this is, so just by shifting that
all of a sudden people said, like, I'll try that.
Right.
It was really amazing.
Or even in terms of the bike work,
as I said I've been doing bike work for a long time.
About four years ago, I decided I wasn't going to work
with any bike organizations.
So we were going to do community-based bike rides,
giveaway bikes, but we weren't going to partner
with any bike organizations.
Why not?
Because if you partner with bike organizations,
you know what it becomes about?
About the bike.
The bike.
Yeah.
It becomes about the bike.
Right.
And then they helmet shame you
and then you get the unintentional bike shaming.
We started partnering with arts organizations
and it changed everything.
I mean, so that was like, and it was just
arts organizations are about the experience.
Right.
Yeah.
So, right.
So now we're managing people's emotional experience.
And that's what I, that was like the light bulb,
I said, Oh, we're using a bike
but what we're really doing
is creating new, positive emotional connections for people
to disrupt what they already know.
Right.
'Cause that's what they're doing, right.
Yeah, that's interesting.
I mean,
the more I think about it,
the biggest barrier is the welcome mat.
You know what I mean?
Because especially in the context of cycling
because there's so much gear and
anybody who goes into a bike shop,
like a pro bike shop, you feel insecure
because you don't know what the right question to ask is
and you see all this fancy stuff
and everybody's speaking a language
you don't quite understand.
But making people feel comfortable
that this is accessible to them.
All that other stuff comes later
but it's getting them in the door.
Dude, you hit the nail on the head.
And I, really the way you characterize it,
when you talked about the feeling of insecurity,
what happens is-
I say that as like a,
like a well-to-do white dude who has a lot
of miles under my belt.
And when I go to a bike shop-
You still.
I still kind of feel that way.
But you saying that out loud changes everything.
You see what I'm saying that in terms of that, when you say
that what I have to actually do
is kind of like what I was saying earlier,
how do we see the person?
How do we see the community?
How do I see that person
as they just don't have knowledge or do I go,
you know what, that person is coming
and they're questioning themselves.
They're feeling a little insecure.
They don't have the confidence here
that they have in their normal life.
So there...
So let me manage that.
And if you think that's, what's going on
you come up with different strategies, right?
Right.
If you think they're uknowledgable, what do you do?
You spew knowledge.
Information.
Statistics.
(indistinct)
But if you go, no,
they're actually having this emotional insecurity,
this lack of confidence.
They wanna...
You know what I'm saying.
Then you go well, what do I have to do to handle that?
And that's a whole different set of strategies.
A whole different set of strategies.
And then you can talk about information if you handle that
that part of it, it just, that makes all the difference.
And that's what I'm saying.
It's like, that was the epiphany about working in schools
and working with families.
That how I view what the challenge is,
is totally shifted.
So now I can actually address that challenge.
I can really put my energy towards that
emotional experience that we're having.
And I think you, and I would agree that a person
the emotional experience they have is more real
than what that's real.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
How did you get into all this?
I literally, I came here to go to college,
my 18 year old ego made me want to play football
at the University of Minnesota instead of the (laughs)
Ripon College or whatever.
I had a lot of offers to small schools
and very few to big schools, but like I said
my 18 year old, ego was like no dude.
Big 10.
And so I came to the University of Minnesota
to play football
and I learned something really quickly in college,
everybody's big, everybody's fast, right.
And high school speed kills, right.
And college speed can still get killed, right.
It was like everybody was big and fast
and I was majoring in engineering and it was killing me.
And I was on the scout team.
You know what I mean?
When you're running in other people's play-
But you got a scholarship so you could come here.
So I can come here.
But I quit.
But I got an engineering scholarship
which is even weirder, right.
So I got an academic scholarship, so I stayed
and, but I quit playing football.
And as soon as I quit playing football, I got fat.
And so I joined a gym off campus that was downtown
and parking was crazy so I started biking to the gym.
And one day I didn't stop
and I just like I started to enjoy it so I started biking.
And that competitive part of me made me do,
I wanted a different bike and different gear
and then I did a race.
And I met a friend Louis Moore, who was older than me
who became a partner in crime for,
big adventures, single day, two 25 mile races.
We did a five day challenge from Denver.
We rode from Denver to Minneapolis in five days,
our goal at that point was race across America or something.
Right.
But as we started doing it
I just realized there weren't any black people out there.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And so we helped a group of black women
prepare for the AIDS ride from Minneapolis, Chicago.
And I just was like,
that was more exciting than biking
and so that, we started the Major Taylor Bicycling
Club of Minnesota.
Yeah, so explain who Major Taylor was.
So Major Taylor was the first American born black champion
in any sport in 1889 in cycling.
And he is-
So crazy.
Yeah, and just he was an amazing athlete.
I mean, just really his story,
he was an amazing athlete at a time when bicycling
was the greatest sport in the world.
And at a time when racism was at its worst
it was just post Jim Crow.
And one of the elements of his story
that I really think is beneficial is that he partnered
with a man from Indiana named Birdie Munger.
Birdie Munger was an older, white,
big wheel racer
who partnered with Major Taylor in Indianapolis,
and ultimately moved to Worcester,
Massachusetts to open a bike business.
But I think many people talk about Major Taylor's challenges
and his triumphs, and he was an amazing athlete
and there's lots there.
I think the fact that they were able to ally
across race in 1889 and
he did his first race, his first professional race under 16.
Wow.
His first real-
What were they racing back then?
So they were racing road bikes.
And really, the real exciting part
of what they did was they were doing velodrome racing.
So in Madison Square Garden,
Madison Square Garden was built,
the version in 1889, that was built, was a velodrome.
Get out.
And they had 25,000 people watching bike races
in New York, in the velodrome.
That is a history I've never heard.
It is unbelievable how big it was.
And the first, his debut like
race when he became a sensation
was in New York at Madison Square Garden in 1887
and it was a velodrome.
It was a six day.
So they talking about the six day races.
It was six days of nonstop racing.
Nonstop, just going around?
Six days, nine days you could stop.
But their goal was to...
I mean, this was-
Whoever got the most accumulated miles in those six days.
Yep, the most accumulated miles in six days.
On a track.
And he finished it-
In Madison Square Garden.
He finished at 2300 miles.
So, I mean, it's-
Wow.
It's just, it's an unbelievable accomplishment
but you have to remember in the turn of the century
the bicycle was the pinnacle of technological achievement.
Like, we don't really think about that in a way.
And what you said earlier
about it being a symbol of freedom,
it actually was a symbol of freedom
for women, for black people, for...
It was really, the automobile was undependable
and horses were slow and
so the bicycle represented something significantly different
and Major Taylor and Birdie Munger understood that.
Like, I really, I believe that and I think that is why he,
for me really, it was...
And I discovered his book
accidentally in the basement of a bike shop
that I was working in.
And he was just a forgotten hero.
He's completely forgotten.
I mean, it's like a movie.
Yeah.
And still we have not made a good Major Taylor movie.
I mean, I talked a little bit about him with
do you know who Justin Williams is?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So Justin's been on the show
and what he's doing in LA with Legion is like unbelievable.
Right.
But don't you think Justin Williams is what you talked
about earlier in terms of the hip hop community.
Oh yeah.
Right.
He's right at the cross section of those two worlds
and he's able to bring that sensibility into-
That's right.
Not just his racing and being an elite cyclist
but into this idea of owning outdoor spaces.
That's right.
And I'm telling you, and I know Justin, actually
I have a great picture of him with my son
in my son race bike's too in the picture.
And it was such an amazing picture 'cause he was
probably 13 and this was three years ago here.
He was in town for a race.
And I've talked with him a lot
because I also know Rahsaan Bahati really well.
And just, but Justin is what you were describing.
He is that young, black American hip hop generation
who said, I can really integrate myself without,
he couldn't-
And it's not about,
and in that transgressive way of not trying to assimilate,
he's like I'm starting my own team.
I'm not going to Europe.
That's right.
I'm not doing that.
I like the fixie culture.
I think we can do something here in the United States
and get people excited about
the kind of bike racing that I Excel at,
which is criteriums.
That's exactly right.
That's what I'm saying, that he represents that sensibility
and that fearlessness and his understanding of
where the money flows, how I can do it,
how I build the brand in the value
of in owning my own brand.
Like that's really powerful.
And bringing that hip hop sensibility
into the garments, right?
Like that's writing a line that is aspirational
for a young kid who sees that 'cause-
That's right.
It's freaking dope and you can't buy it
unless you're on the team.
So-
That's right.
He creates that like, it's that Supreme model of like,
you can't get it, man.
There's high demand and low supply.
And that's what I mean, I think is brilliant.
And I like, I'm working really hard
to try to get him to come to Minneapolis this summer.
So if you're listening in Justin, I'm gonna keep calling.
But no, but I really mean that.
I think that is a great example.
And I think even fixie culture is another one
of those weird stories that we don't really realize that
the idea of fixie culture actually also
has black roots and it's as black roots
in the Caribbean community of New York.
Because when the Caribbean has moved here to New York
the only bank they knew was fixies.
So fixie culture and Europeans said,
that's what's bike for Europeans.
In our three spoke wheels on them
and like making them all crazy colors
and all that kind of stuff.
And that draw all, fixie culture in the United States
was really started by the Caribbeans in New York.
Yeah.
Yeah, the true history versus
the sort of conventional narrative it's fascinating.
Another example of that is
we've had Selema Masekela on the show
and he sent me his Afro surf book.
Do you have his book?
Yep.
It's unbelievable.
And this complete revisionist history
of where surfing comes from and how
deeply embedded it is in,
black cultures across the world.
Yeah.
Tracing back to prior to,
what we initially believed began in Hawaii.
Right.
And that's what I meant about changing the narrative.
Like, that's like a really a fundamental idea
that the instincts of this current group
is changing the narrative.
So you don't have imposter syndrome when you show up.
You know what I mean?
Or you don't question your own integrity,
your own authenticity, you're...
Like that...
'Cause that matters to people.
And there's a legacy here.
And you own your part of that legacy.
You're good doing that.
And I think that's really, and as (indistinct)
I know Hugh, 'cause my son was a snowboarder
and he's a competitive snowboarder.
He was ranked 12th in the country,
last year and this year he got an invitation
to travel with the US Olympic team during COVID
and he turned it down.
What?
Like I know.
And it really, it was about culture, right.
He was in Park City last year.
He was in Vail last summer with the team
and got a chance to be with them.
And it's just,
it was really interesting that he just said, that's not me.
Like, that's not really my thing
That's a Justin Williams move.
And I'm telling you,
I'm telling you at the time I was like,
dude really, you're saying I didn't get it
but then I had to dig deeply and think about his decision.
And at the same time, another young man, Brian Rice
I don't know if you've seen him.
Brian Rice, 16 year old from Detroit
who just is going to worlds.
He qualified for world championships
and they were partners in crime.
You can see them on Instagram together.
They'd train last summer together.
It's happening.
I mean, and that's what I mean.
And so I was on a call with Selema and Brian and my son
and those other people, because Selema also sees
the fact that he actually is a pioneer.
And also the narrative
that all snowboarders don't compete
you can create the culture, right.
From that's maybe a more advantageous point
for creating culture where he is, right.
Right, 'cause he was never competitive.
He's an ambassador.
That's exactly right.
And he talks about his legacy of getting there
through skateboarding, through surfing, right.
And board culture, boarders, the culture snowboarders
is really similar, right.
I mean, it's just a really interesting culture
of that anyway.
And so I think, and we've been steeped in it.
So I think that's the other thing that
I've really had the fortune
to be on the inside of that community.
See the good, the bad and the ugly,
in terms of how it works.
But ultimately snowboarding culture is...
And matter of fact, I did an article
where I believe snowboarding
is the culture that can integrate winter sports.
Yeah.
I mean that's-
Well, if there's one sport that can it's that
but the difference between snowboarding and surfing,
yes, they're both board cultures but
surfing just by virtue of geography.
That's right.
You have to go to these exotic places where
it's an indigenous part, a way of life, right.
So you're exposed to all these different types of people
whereas snowboarding is really kind of like a white thing.
And so even there, it's a white thing-
Because of geography.
Because of geography, right.
And actually and how can we predict disparities?
Geography.
Yeah.
I mean, that's like the part I'd be
that's, what's so deep, that's exactly right.
And that's what I was saying.
These guys and so actually,
even that is an effort we're working on.
We're positing to...
Admittedly and Burton Snowboard is actually
a really cool partner because they're being
thoughtful about this.
As we're saying, what we need to do is create
small snowboard Hills in the community.
And snowboarding is unique in that you don't need
a lot of elevation to build a really cool snowboard park.
So what we're trying to do, we start, we are
experimenting here in Minneapolis,
and we want to do more locations.
Like skate parks sort of.
Yeah, like a skate park.
A skate park with snow.
But it's only, I mean is 150 feet of elevation
with the skate park on it, where you teach, right.
You help people have positive, emotional connections, right.
You help them figure out gear
and then you make it progressive.
So the progressive experience starts
five, 10 minutes from home
then 30 minutes to an hour from home,
then you go 13 hours to Colorado.
And then all of a sudden, it all makes sense.
So what we're trying to do is put people
through experiences, the, build the value
of what we're talking about before you try to
do this big leap, right.
Yeah.
But this city is flat.
(Rich laughs)
We got valleys.
That was the first thing I noticed.
No, we got valleys.
Right.
But not in the city city.
No.
In the city city.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm saying.
If we have a hundred...
If we need 150, 200 feet of elevation,
and that's what, the reason skateboarders
coming out of Minnesota are really good
is because they're doing hot laps
on a small amount of elevation.
So they're not doing-
So they're getting way more runs.
Way more runs.
Yeah.
They're getting way more runs in
in the same amount of time.
So you got, so all you need is 150 foot rope tow, right?
And you put an obstacles, you can build jumps,
you can work on everything and you can do it
in an elevation where you get more runs in.
And that's what I'm saying.
So why do we...
So we,
these flat Lander locations actually could be great
entrees in the snowboard.
Right, that's interesting.
It's the same thing as Chicago.
Same thing at Detroit, same...
Right, all these flat Lander places
have these small valleys where we could actually,
and they're close to the city, right.
Because all the old industry happened close to the rivers
which is in the center of the cities.
So we've got a, really an interesting foundation
for what could we do to make snowboarding, right?
Something, is cheap and affordable, close to home
because right now we don't have...
Now you don't need a hundred dollar Lyft ticket.
You do a $10 Lyft ticket.
Yeah, there's no chairlift involved.
There's no chairlift involved.
That's what I'm...
Right.
So this is where again now, but back to my point
so now we're thinking what was the challenge?
Right.
Once we define a different challenge
we can kind of come up with different solutions.
And I think that we spiral that up
and all the outdoor stuff-
Right.
You probably know Dan Buettner, right?
Yeah.
So Dan's a friend, Minneapolis native.
Oh, he'd be mad at you.
'Cause he's a St. Paul.
Oh, is he St. Paul?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, dude.
Sorry, Dan.
That's all right.
He emailed me yesterday.
(Anthony laughs)
But one of the things he always talks about is how
this region is exceptional in terms of creating
an environment that's conducive to a healthy lifestyle
and where I'm going with this is
rather than trying to convince people
they need to go outside or give them a battery of reasons.
You have to create an environment
that kind of marshals people in that direction.
So the idea of creating that kind of
snowboarding experience that is centrally located
accessible, urban, not intimidating,
has a good welcome mat
is part of that thinking that philosophy, right,
That's exactly right.
But this area is well known for all of its biking lanes
and everything that they've done to facilitate that.
So how does that work?
Like that's sort of the conventional wisdom
but how does that work in terms of
accessibility for the underserved communities
and the underprivileged and the black and people of color.
And I really love the way you kind of package that up
because what I think is
that what you're saying is absolutely right.
The city and the way (indistinct) the city
and the region makes significant investments
in public green space, active living, bike lanes.
I mean, you travel...
We have a, literally, there's a belief that there's a park
within one mile of every home in the twin cities.
And the goal of the commitment is there will be a bike lane
within one mile of every front door in the twin cities.
So that's a municipal commitment.
Because we are a city making that commitment,
we have an amazing park system
which is also funded by taxes a regional...
And I'm actually a commissioner
on our regional authority around parks
and so I'm pushing this.
We therefore have a responsibility
to do whatever it takes to make sure that these
amenities are equitably participated in
by all of our communities.
So that's the foundation.
We have a responsibility for that.
Therefore, the programming that we do
has to enlist the things we've been talking about.
It has to solve the obstacle of a bike.
It has to solve the obstacle
of the skills needed to be successful at it.
of the historical reality that we have created
in our public spaces
that says black people don't belong here.
Right?
Right.
The last thing we have to solve is the culture
that says whoever's moving the fastest
with the most momentum and the most skill
has the most right.
I mean, that is the last part that really...
'Cause that's what happens, right.
People make up their mind, they get out there
and then they get screamed at by somebody
going faster than them, right.
And it trickles down, it's the roadie against
the guy who's on a city bike and it's a city bike
against the kid on a bike.
It's a whole parking order to that.
And then it's that kid against the walker
and a woman with a stroller.
You know what I mean?
And it's like, and so that culture is what flows downhill.
And so those are the things that as a municipality,
as a region, as a city committed to those things,
we have to handle that too.
And we can do that.
And I tell you what, the cost of giving
every kid in the Minneapolis public school system
a bike in third grade, what would that take?
What would that be?
That's not even-
I mean, it's a blip on the radar-
That's exactly right.
And if we did that, that now that's equity.
We're redistributing resources, right
in a real way to serve the needs of people.
Those are big ideas and that,
so when of you talk about Dan Buettner
and I'm a fan of his work
and one of the biggest reasons I'm a fan of his work
is because what he really points out
in blue zones and continues to point out in this work
is that the fundamental of active living
is baked into the cultural reality of the people, right.
So when he talked about those Sardinian
fishermen and their walk to the thing
and then having wine and the Okinawan Housewives,
the seventh day Adventist community
and that really was the ultimate measure
of health is actually connectedness.
Like, that's...
I mean, the ultimate measure of health
is actually connectedness.
So if we make the goal
of all of our active living activities,
building community we win
and rather than fitness, rather than this.
So that's another shift in terms of my own growth
is that that's the ultimate goal
of everything I do in terms of outdoors.
Right.
'Cause if you achieve that, if you create that level of
deep connectivity and community
everything else flows from that
There you go.
That's exactly right.
And I'm just...
That is, again, it just sounds too simple.
Right.
But ultimately that's a huge shift for us
as outdoor advocates, is a huge shift
for us as active living advocates,
even people who are focused on food as medicine.
And that really
if you build community around, whatever that thing is
if you make the result of that experience,
building community, you win.
And people and then it will perpetuate, right.
It will become self validate.
Yeah.
The losing battle is trying to get people interested
in something that feels like an obligation or a burden or-
That's right.
A situation in which they have to go
out of their way or inconvenience themselves.
That's right.
And that's what I really, I mean
that was like from, I mean, and
lots of takeaways from blue zones.
But I think one of the biggest takeaways
for me personally was,
because I talk about the Okinawan Housewives all the time
was the fact that sitting in a chair is killing us, right.
And even that simple idea
versus sitting on the floor and getting up and sitting down
and getting up and sitting down and getting up
and that idea of how do you integrate movement
into your life is really a very and rather than
that's why it's melanin emotion and that melanin on bikes,
you know what I mean?
Or melanin on a run.
Right
(Anthony laughs)
Right.
Yeah, yeah.
We went out to ride bikes the other night.
What's the ride share here,
it's called like Nice Bike?
Nice Ride.
Nice Ride, yeah.
And it wouldn't let us, it was like,
we tried like four different credit cards
a whole bunch of us trying to rent bikes
and I think it was because of what's going on here.
Like they just locked it down
and they don't want people riding bikes around.
And you know what else they might be doing it
for out-of-town credit cards.
Maybe.
'Cause that's what-
They don't want out of towners riding, taking nice rides.
Well, because they're, vandalism people get whatever it is
it might be more of that than anything.
And that's interesting, I'm going to check that now, but
even that is Lyft, you know that right?
Yeah I know.
Right.
So what I will say is Lyft has really done an
interesting job here of coming in
and connecting to community advocates
around promoting their programming.
So I think they've actually
done an interesting job of that but
that Nice Ride is one of those efforts that really,
it was a problem when we first opened it
and we actually created and worked with them
and created an equity initiative to specifically focus
on communities of color
and low to moderate income communities
with pricing, with introduction
with what, the welcome mat.
I mean, we created a series of rides and activities
that were all about connectedness and that really worked
and that ultimately turned into our slow roll movement.
That really, that whole thing kind of-
The slow roll being like the
group participatory rides that you guys
organize.
Yeah.
Well, one thing about Nice Ride
you got to fix that user interface, man.
It makes you click through like,
20 pages of disclaimers and stuff like that.
I'm like that's a barrier.
Yeah.
No, I think that that was a
baked into the very first versions of it
because of it was sponsored too.
So like we had healthcare organizations as the key sponsors
and so I, and the city and so I think,
you're absolutely right about that.
Yeah.
They look like nice bikes though.
Yeah, and the skim of like city, kind of rental bikes.
Yeah.
No, it's a good system
and they've always upgraded the fleet,
and they make sense here
because our gr footprint is so small.
Right.
Three miles in any direction
and you have covered major territory in Minneapolis.
It's been interesting to see
how various cities have responded to COVID
and I often look at Manhattan
and you see those images of the streets closed
and everybody's just walking and they're riding bikes.
And I'm like, here's the one moment
in a lifetime where you could like change everything
and just say, no more residential vehicles in Manhattan.
Just delivery trucks and maybe some,
ride shares or whatever
but let's close off a bunch of these thoroughfares
and adopt a more European blue zones model
because people seem to be
enjoying it.
That's right.
And the cafes are popping up
on the street with the outdoor eating and all of that.
And it felt like an opportunity to really remodel
and re-imagine the urban landscape
but I don't think it's...
I don't know how many places really jumped on that.
Well-
And obviously
there's so many...
I mean, it's such a difficult thing to accomplish,
but it just felt like an opportunity that
I wish I'd been kind of capitalized on a little bit more.
Well, what's happening now is that,
this is our year to capitalize on it, right.
Last year's budget would set when the pandemic set,
the programming was set
so I'm waiting to see what happens this season.
So I'm actually more hopeful
because we're still in the pandemic in spring,
but I think that it's those habits now
and the work of advocates is not getting people
on bike is keeping people on bikes.
Right.
So that's the work this year.
And so I think there's, again, that's where
we have to make a shift in terms of what we're doing.
I do...
I mean, I actually laugh 'cause I don't know if you,
but if someone told you all you needed to do to get people
on bikes to a start of global pandemic.
Would you have done it?
You know what I mean?
Most bike cafe.
You can think about that.
Right.
But you know what I mean?
But that was kind of what happened, but even think about
the number of cities that actually closed streets.
Like they never thought...
They closed streets to traffic and made them available
for people to walk on.
Here in the twin cities,
we have what we call the grand rounds
that wrap around the chain of lakes we have here
and over to the Mississippi river.
And they closed them last year to traffic.
Totally closed in the traffic and they were packed.
So I think that one, two things happen the city did it
and nobody lost their mind and people showed up.
And the research we have initially says
that communities of color showed up in heightened numbers
compared to what we've done historically,
women showed up in higher numbers
and then what they have historically, right?
I mean, children, people with children.
So we actually kind of proved the point
that we were going well, what would it take to do that?
And that's what it took.
And so again, once those people were out,
we decided, okay we're going to handle
those introductory experiences, right.
And so that became the goal of our efforts last summer,
was those introductory experiences.
Even flowing from the bikes for essential workers was,
well you got a new bike now,
what's the first thing you should know.
And taking people in parking lots.
I mean, originally, I mean, like take an adult
and saying, okay, these are the handlebars,
Right.
So when you're waiting for a thing, this is what you do.
You put your pedal here and put your foot on it
and you're not rolling yet,
but now but squeeze your brakes when you're sitting still
on your bike 'cause that keeps it from rolling.
Lean your bike over to you when you step over it,
instead of throwing (indistinct).
Like that's just so rudimentary, right?
Lean your bike over to you
instead of throwing your leg over the seat
and you, everybody tries to do that.
They all get a bike
and they try to throw their leg over the seat.
I'm like, dude, you're 40.
Your flexibility there's none.
Right.
But instead of saying that, I say
let me make that easy lean your bike over and step over it.
Well, the closing of the streets
and all the people out pouring into them
I mean, that's the community
like that's the breeding ground for the community.
So the question then becomes, can you make that stick?
That's right.
Everybody's so intent on like getting back to normal or
some version of the way things used to be.
And we're myopic to the opportunity
that we're being presented with.
Yeah.
I agree and I think,
but even with that,
like so that's again, when we say, well, what is our work?
Our work, kind of related to the trial
is to help people visualize a future that's different.
Like it isn't getting back to normal.
Like, I think that's really important what you said
as we get that is,
we want to get back to freedom.
What we perceive as freedom.
That's really more do you want to,
what is it you want to get back to?
But the number of people that have had
more time with their kids this year
than they ever have before
and appreciate them differently is tremendous.
They may never go back to work
the same way they went back to work, right?
So it is this thing where we have to help people
focus on the realization of these other positive benefits
and connect the emotional outcome of those benefits to them
if we want them to stick.
And that's, again, that's not the American way,
we're already selling, we're all the marketers have kind of
found their way to make COVID-19
the springboard to buy more stuff.
You know what I mean?
And so I think, again for all the advocates out there
our work this year is identify everybody who got a bike
and help them have a positive experience as someone.
Help them have an expansive
progressive growth oriented experience
with that bike they purchased,
and everybody who purchased a bike
'cause they're already sold this year.
Yeah.
You can't get bikes.
In April, in April 15th, you can't get a bike.
How much of that is because of the supply chain overseas
in Asia and how much of that is, they're just not
set up to build enough bikes for, to meet the demand.
I think it's both right.
The supply chain got shut down last year,
a little bit in that affected things, but they've ramped up.
But the bike shops are selling everything
they have everything they can get
and people people want to bike.
I mean, I just think that some people want to bike
and even some of the bike shops that I frequently go to
I've gone to them and said,
let us lead a community ride
for all the new people who bought a bike.
That kind of, like they have to be
in the programming business too.
See, so that was, right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like do the bike shops consider themselves
in the business of offering programming.
They don't.
And that that's another, sort of missed opportunity.
I mean, we've seen the explosion of Peloton
which is a digital version of that.
And there are exceptions there are extraordinary bike shops
that do a great job with that.
And you see what Justin is doing with Rafa his sponsor.
Like he's always dropping by the shop and they got coffee
and like he's trying to create that.
And also kind of rewrite the Rafa story
because it's such a,
sort of gentleman's super expensive brand.
But I think, and I think a lot of bike shops
took stabs at that earlier on,
but couldn't get enough traction
but I feel like there is an opportunity
because people want to be with each other and
you can, for the most part,
safely ride with other people right now in the outdoors.
And we need more of that.
Yeah.
I just say to everybody,
nature is the only safe space, right?
So whatever gets you in nature
is worth the effort.
And it literally is whatever gets you in nature,
whatever gets you outdoors moving is absolutely worth it.
Yeah.
And again, what you're describing,
with Justin, with Rafa,
all of them, but what's the ultimate goal of
those activities is building community.
And I think, again, that that's where
are the bike shops in the program in business,
if they think their good job is building community it is.
Right.
That's really the...
That's the way we have to approach this and-
It's in their economic self-interest anyway
because it breeds loyalty to the brand.
That's right.
And in the nature of the way people work is progression.
So there'll be buying a more expensive bike next time.
If you get them going-
Oh, there's no end to the amount
of money that gets done intimately
over the course of their lifetime.
That's right.
If you hook them.
That's exactly right.
You hook them.
You hook them on the experiences.
And I think that is really, I mean,
that's what I mean.
That's what I see, with people in terms of
just generally how we get people to stick with this.
That's how we need to get people to stick with this.
We actually do have to have them
have these new emotional experiences, right.
They have to heal self-discovery, they build community
they create some new memories
and I think people are going to be hooked.
And so, again that's where we,
advocates have to shift our work now.
Right.
So you're, what are you like 62, 61?
62.
You are fit.
You look like, I mean, you're not a day over 35.
It's crazy.
And your Twitter, your Twitter profile,
your Twitter handle is like
I am anti-aging or something like that, right.
(both laugh)
Yeah.
You are aging in reverse.
So what's the daily routine look like for you?
My workout is really compact.
I try to do a 75 minute workout
and that's my goal of 75 minutes.
In the summer I'll bike a lot more.
I'll get out and biking.
But the routine is really kind of built around,
I try to start the day with a 75 minute workout.
That's a mixture of cardio
and some kind of strength training.
And during COVID what,
I never thought I'd work out indoors,
but what I really discovered
in the last really 12, 15 months is kettlebell.
And I've found a really good kettlebell
kind of program introduction to it, here locally.
And it just really has been a monumental success
in terms of me sticking with my program
and doing it at home.
You don't need like some full gym.
No, you really don't.
And the key is like, what's the minimum thing you can, like
you always have to be planning
for the minimum thing you can do
so then you have no excuse to skip it, right.
And that's the strategy that I started about
five years ago, just like, what's the minimum...
Like, what's the thing that I always can do.
And that's, seventy-five minutes
wound up being that thing, right.
Is that, that I never have an excuse
to skip a seven minute workout.
Right.
And peppered in there,
all kinds of different skiing and boarding, and-
Right, and then staying at them.
(indistinct) and biking and all the kind
of stuff that you and your family does.
Yeah.
I think that has been
the other thing I kind of figure out too is
is that you don't use those activities for training,
you train for those activities.
Like in, especially as you get older
that's really important to make that clear delineation
between those two activities.
Meaning what?
Meaning that, you can't use snowboard for training.
Yeah.
You have to train for snowboard.
Right.
And so especially as you get older.
I'm 54 now and I've really had to confront that
in a way that I've never had to before.
That's right.
And the sooner you learn that the better.
So I love talking to 35 year old dudes,
'cause you're still invincible at 35.
Like you still remember your best day
(laughs)
and you kind of base everything on that.
But I think
that's really what I've found.
And snowboarding is a great example.
This year, listen to me, don't snowboard with 13 year olds.
So I once, this year I actually
was snowboarding with some 13 year olds and decided,
I was hanging with them, we were just talking
and they've only been snowboarding a year, right.
So we're doing these rollers
and I don't know what I did.
I went over to this one roller
and came down and fell right on my chest.
Right.
And I'm going, my ribs hurt.
Yeah.
And hurt ribs, hurt.
I just want you to know that it's just like
because you use them for breathing and
it's like, man that was rough.
You don't bounce back as quick.
So yeah.
Don't hang out with 13 year olds that's dangerous for you.
All right, man.
Well, last thing, and then I'll let you go.
I want to leave people with,
really your philosophy of outdoor space
and really broadening access to it
for all different types of people, particularly people
who have lacked that kind of connection in their lives.
So what can you kind of take us out with on that subject?
I really believe that
outdoors nature and adventure,
like those like that kind of those activities
are the best place for us to actually grow
and experience this thing around social, emotional learning.
Like I think when we really talk about the outcomes
of what we do, then we'll be talking about sport.
I think sports sports, as we know
it has convinced us that there's
this Petri dish for human development, right.
And youth development.
And I say, not, unless you're intentional
but something about outdoors is always about personal best.
It's always about situational awareness, right.
Is always about...
They're always about skills development.
So the best athlete won't always be the best climber, right?
It's the person who masters the skills.
The best skier will not be the best athlete.
The most athletic person will be the person
that focuses on a master in the skills, right?
So they're progressive skill-based
they create opportunities for us to
have self-discovery, their personal best oriented.
Again, this idea of controlling yourself
in an environment that you have no control over, right?
Like that's the stuff that life is made of.
And I actually think that outdoors and nature
offer that opportunity to everybody who shows up.
Everybody who shows up can have that experience outdoors.
And for communities of color, for marginalized community,
what I know is that those experiences
are the ones that build your humanity, your confidence,
that help you understand beyond racism's impact on you,
in a simple example, and you all can go test this.
I believe that women who spend time outdoors
have a much higher body concept than the average person.
Because everything in the world wants women
to hate their bodies.
I think outdoors activities, hiking, biking, climbing, and
there are these things we do,
it actually re-frames your relationship to your body
around this ability to do work instead of the aesthetic.
Right?
And so this balance that nature outdoors
and adventure offers to the messages.
You know what I mean?
Is really, really Seminole.
And I believe that's an opportunity
for everybody and for communities of color,
it's an opportunity that we don't see in our arsenal.
So that's my message to them
is tell me about the humans you want your kids to be
and my answer is always going to be take them outside.
Boom!
Beautifully put my friend.
We did it, Anthony.
Well, thank you.
How do you feel?
Thanks so much.
I feel good.
It's good to meet you.
That was good, man.
That was very cool.
I appreciate all the work that you're doing, man.
It's cool that you know a lot of the people that I admire.
We just scratched the surface.
Yeah, I'm sure there's many more.
So I'd love to do this with you again at some point.
So that was really fantastic.
Yeah, I would love too.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
And welcome.
Peace.
Thanks.
Plants.